[Music]
so there is a lot of data hitting out
there this rel this uh from fox business
americans are quickly losing confidence
in the us economy
according to a new survey published this
week reflecting heightened concerns
among consumers about sky-high inflation
and the rising price of everyday goods a
gallup survey published wednesday shows
americans have low levels of confidence
in the economy what's more most
americans expect the economy to
deteriorate
further
about 76 percent said the economy is
getting worse
compared to 20 percent who believe
it is
improving
so christina what we have to do when we
see stuff like this is there's three or
four things going on as far as i'm
concerned
thing one is
there is some real inflation
thing two is is not gonna kill you
it's bad it's ugly when you fill up your
car and you have a heart attack when you
look at the price
it's ugly when you consider that house
prices are doing what they're doing in a
lot of areas
it's not gonna kill you i don't like it
i don't want it to stay around i don't
think it's going to stay around that's
thing one
thing two is the news media
particularly our friends at fox
want to tell you over and over and over
and over and over and over and over
again how bad the economy is
because if there's one thing that will
get a politician thrown out of office
of either party it is that the economy
is bad
so if you want to dump all of the
democrats in the street at the midterm
the best way to do that's convince
everyone that the economy is bad
so there's a little bit of an agenda
here
just a wee bit
and so yes the economy is bad and yes
there's some things going on but it you
know
the news media left and right and
confused whatever they are
they make all of their viewership based
on fearporn
if we can make you afraid of kovid and
think you're going to die
if we can make you afraid of the economy
and just keep peddling the fear porn
you will keep dialing in you can't stay
away from it you can't take your eyes
off the train wreck
and so then your
adrenaline spikes your
uh
chemistry and your body starts changing
your heart rate changes your eyes dilate
you stay pissed off all the time or
afraid all the time and and it keeps you
coming back it's the same thing as a
tornado warning by the
oh god the weather people
so uh when i was a kid we were like oh
there's a tornado and now we shut down
schools because there might be a tornado
three weeks from now
so uh it's a different world but it's
that there's a little bit of all that
going on
so you know when you hear that the
economy is bad or that americans have
lost
confidence in the economy our message
would be um
yeah it sucks right now but it's okay
yeah well i think even going with the
analogy of a storm if there's a
hurricane coming what do you do you
batten down the hatches you make sure
everything is in place and solidified so
i hope people can take that kind of
uneasy feeling they feel in their
stomachs when they see that news article
when they see the fear porn and they go
you know what we need to make sure our
financial house is in order we need to
really make sure we're on a budget that
we're paying off our debt and that we're
saving for an emergency because you know
if something does happen the more you
have your financial house in order the
less of a hit you'll take and that's why
your book is called financial peace we
want you to feel at peace regardless of
what the storm looks like yeah so the
good news about the storm is you can use
it as a warning to get your crap
together right uh the bad news is you
don't want to overreact
and because people go cray-cray when
they go down these rabbit holes i mean
they just when you're in panic mode your
critical thinking skills shut down
panic mode is run right and you know
your brain says get out of the way the
car you're going to be smashed right and
you're not supposed to have a critical
thinking about oh i wonder what that
fender will do to my left leg you know
we don't want to have a discussion about
this get out of the dead gum road you
know but that's what that's your brain
is designed to do that lonely talks
about that all the time
so the thing is this guys when you start
seeing the stuff on the news
just kind of take it with a grain of
salt some of it is politically driven
some of it is if we can keep you upset
we can keep you as a viewer
and some of it is real
and you kind of got to parse through
that a little bit and go okay yeah gas
is really five dollars and that was
really biden on biden's desk he really
screwed this whole energy thing up bad
uh oh yeah uh supply chains all screwed
up and that drove prices up on a bunch
of stuff wasn't biden's fault he didn't
do that he didn't cause the pandemic and
he didn't cause a supply chain mess up
after the pandemic could he have done
some things to help probably but he
couldn't have stopped it from happening
some of this stuff is just the result of
it's a it's the aftertaste it's the
tsunami that came ashore after the
earthquake at sea
and uh that that's some of that is
what's going on there but the energy
stuff's 100 on him he just screwed that
up course he has no idea but in the name
of being woke or left or
energy free or whatever i mean or
whatever he's trying to do you know get
everybody in to buy an elon musk car or
whatever he's trying to do
um
he's you know he's screwing up
the economy because here's the thing gas
doubling
goes into the truck that delivers the
bread
and into the price of the bread
therefore
okay so this is a problem so yeah so
he's contributing to it so yeah he's
going to get his party thrown out for
various reasons and that's
probably a great thing so it's okay it's
gonna work out but the point is you
cannot read these articles and go into
freakout mode
absolutely not yeah you gotta really
focus on the controllables you know what
can you control you can't control
macroeconomics of the us government you
can't control whether gas prices are
more expensive next week but you can
control your budget you can't adjust
things as necessary so that your family
can afford your lifestyle and you can
afford the things that you need to pay
for focus on the controllables yeah
i'll never forget watching a local
weather forecaster
and her voice was going up the octaves
were going up and if you're in this it's
not like a beagle chasing a rabbit right
i mean she's just going crazy there's a
tornado coming
you know and and i swear the woman said
if you have a football helmet
put a football helmet on and go sit in
the
shower if you don't have a safer place
to hide
and so somewhere i've got visualized
this redneck sitting in a shower with a
football helmet on because this woman
said to do this and i'm just thinking
this is out of control guys you know
you know if a tornado hits your trailer
football helmet in the shower ain't
gonna cut it it's just not gonna i mean
it's just not gonna work
i mean i may or may not still wear the
football helmet but
um
all right so this is the world we live
in though and so you have to keep my
point is you have to keep your wits
about you and make good solid decisions
yes you've got five dollar gas
yes house prices are out of control
right now and so what do you do i mean
used cars are going up what kind of
world do we live in you know so
so is right now a good time to buy a
used car no
horrible time to buy music